so here is an equation what is it that
makes us an equation again do you
remember how do I do this is an equation
there's one thing that's sort of like to
give away yeah nothing if something is
equal to something else that equals
makes it an equation ok so that's how I
what this is where I want to solve this
solve it I want to find out look that
thing there see that guy's not a number
is a protein or but he stands for number
and I want to find out what it is ok i'm
going to show you two different ways of
doing this you remember from last week
when you just try to put in numbers into
n and see if eventually one works but
that's very tiresome and very time
consuming ok do you have an answer ok I
want you to hold that thought i'm going
to get to you in a minute Brad I want to
think about before we get to the right
on time how do we get the right answer
ok what can we do with this equation to
get towards a solution so i'm going to
show you two methods ok so you might
like to make to the men's we can go
method one and now what we're trying to
do is get the last line to be an equal
something right m equals something so
you can see I've got this three thats
hanging out in the way and there's a two
here in the way and I don't really want
either them to be there I just want em
so I'm searching for something I can do
to both sides to get closer towards
having and by itself can anyone give me
a suggestion yeah Thank You early what I
was going to say is am gonna be by self
it would still be on the 30 well I want
to get past that I want to get plastic
so I'll do I can think of two things I
can do and I could have in any order I
like to get closer and closer towards
that frankly give a suggestion basically
I first close-up Ramon we do programs to
get free but a police report so I want
to take Francis first suggestion which
is we want to get rid of the plus two
back it's a plus two so what's the
opposite of plus two
mine is too perfect so let's write this
same line exactly the same but just like
remember its balance right so I'm going
2-2 subtract two from both sides like
this so here's my first method okay now
if you have a color or highlight it
would be a perfect I want you to show
underline put a surf or something to
show them doing the same thing to both
sides i'm keeping everything nice and
balanced because if these two things are
equal I can't do something to one side
without doing it to the other that's
excellent okay what will they leave you
with on the left-hand side wants us to
track 22 yeah m / 33 okay perfect you
don't both sides okay excellent so you
can see I've done the left-hand side
these two guys just kind of my heads and
cancel out and the right-hand side 5-2
we all know how to do that okay now i'm
in a similar position I'm better I've
got that stuff as well let me get reduce
guys so it's divided by three much shall
I do yeah okay i'm going to multiply
both sides again i'm doing the same
thing to both sides and i'm going to
highlight that's the case x 3 x 3 and
that's going to give me an answer right
so let's have a go what happens on the
left over the what these guys are going
to cancel yet leaving me with just an
and Brad's going through this right
answer is right okay okay now what's
lovely about this is remember all this
practice work we did on substitution I
can use that to check if I got this
right you never need to doubt right we
think m is equal to 9 let's have a look
at where we started is it true does it
work it does right here's how we know
you can substitute this in your head
it's easy enough right what's 9/3 it's 3
plus 2 I perfect that's exactly what I
want okay thumbs up now I did say I was
going to show you the other way yes
through
you can't work backwards yeah absolutely
well yeah kinda we did that oh I want to
show you another way so over here you've
got your second headed right do you
remember the first time we got rid of
the tube that was the first thing we
wanted to do but you don't have to get
rid of two first you can get rid of the
three fuel line how does it get rid of
the three you know when we did this line
of work what we do yes apply we multiply
through by three is to buy by three you
get rid of that scene only try to the
same thing here so I've got em over 3
i'm going to leave some gaps in you see
why in a second this is just the line as
it is right now and i want to multiply
everything by 3 okay so i'm going to
multiply this by 3 and this point 3 and
this by three do you see what i do now
just be careful you can see i've
multiplied the left hand side by 3 right
i had to multiply everything on the left
hand side but don't miss anything else
okay what's the next line going to be
what's it look like ya I'm x 3 it's a
great question because I'm trying to get
rid of division by three you see that so
if this is division by leg 52 I'm x 52
if it was division by half I'd x half
whatever number happens to be done okay
I'll tell you this m / 3 times 3 is
going to give me just ever 2 x 3 6 & 6 &
5 times you keen okay cool now i'm still
getting better right I've got an M plus
6 15 what do i do to both sides yeah
yeah i'm going to take away 6 from both
science right and again we're gonna
highlight look see i'm doing the same
thing on both sides it all stays
balanced so what does that leave us with
yeah yep the [ __ ] would you just do the
3 times 3 which he was 9 and then you
look poised waste three times three I
live in public is and those 13 times 3
is it a casa di confused about as 949 46
equal 15 to say it's true ah but I can
sense that this three times three one of
them's on the denominator and ones on
the numerator so then not nine right so
that's why in fact that early do you
know and they leave you did ever okay
and remember this is the second approach
like you already know what the answer is
now right and no but if you've gone down
this way first you didn't know that you
have only found that out after the fact
so two different parts to the question
um which one do you like better any take
it to you like Method one better hands
off a method one Jobeth one yeah cool
pens down um I think method to is fine
you can see they're both about the same
speed one of them gets rid of fractions
sooner you might like that in the future
see how this one gets through double
factions but the numbers get bigger push
your multiply or is this one the numbers
stay small but you keep that fraction
all the way through until the end